変分量子固有値ソルバー、つまりVQEは最も初期のハイブリッド量子古典アルゴリズムの一つで、
いくつかの理由から興味深い。まず、このビデオで見ていくように、特定の種類の問題に対して有望なアプローチだ。次に、
歴史的に重要であり、adapt VQEなど多くの拡張アルゴリズムへの道を切り開いた。
そして最後に、VQEはかなりシンプルだ。このアルゴリズムで量子コンピュータと古典コンピュータが何をするのかは理解しやすく、
どう相互作用するかも分かりやすい。VQE計算には四つの主要な構成要素がある。
まず、演算子がある。多くの場合Hamiltonianと呼ばれ、Hと表記する。これは最適化したいシステムの性質を記述したもので、
この演算子の固有ベクトルのうち、最小の固有値に
対応するものを求めることになる。その固有ベクトルは基底状態と呼ばれることが多い。
次に、「ansatz（アンザッツ）」がある。これはドイツ語で「アプローチ」を意味する言葉だ。これは求めている固有ベクトルを近似した量子状態を準備するquantum circuitだ。
実際にansatzはquantum circuitの族だ。なぜならansatz内のgateの一部が
パラメータ化されているからだ。つまり、変化させられるパラメータが入力される。このquantum circuitの族は
基底状態を近似した量子状態の族を準備できる。
次に、estimatorが必要だ。これは現在の変分量子状態に対する演算子Hの期待値を推定する手段だ。
実際に我々が本当に気にするのが単純にこの期待値である場合もある。これを
コスト関数と呼ぶ。また、一つ以上の期待値から始めて書けるより複雑な関数を気にする場合もある。
一つ以上の期待値から書けるより複雑な関数だ。
最後に、古典的なoptimizerが必要だ。これはコスト関数を最小化しようとしてパラメータを変化させるアルゴリズムだ。
量子がどんな役割を果たすかを説明する前に、解きたい問題と一般的なアプローチを概説しよう。
科学と産業に重要な多くの最適化問題を行列値問題として定式化できる。一般的に、
行列の最小固有値とそれに対応する固有ベクトルが求めたいものになる。行列Hは
物理系のエネルギーを記述するHamiltonianである場合がある。最小固有値は基底状態エネルギー
E0となり、固有ベクトルは対応する量子基底状態、多くの場合ψ₀と表記されるものになる。
あるいは行列が、組み合わせ最適化問題に関連する複雑なコスト関数を記述する場合もある。
例えばロジスティクスなどで、固有状態s_suboptは問題の最適解、
例えば配送ネットワークのグラフのカットにラベル付けするバイナリ文字列になる。実際には、
物理科学の外でも関心のある全ての行列に対してHamiltonianという用語が使われることが多い。では、
n行n列の行列に興味があるとしよう。このような問題は、行列について何の仮定も置かずに、
古典的なsolverを使ってnが数百から数千までなら素早く正確に解ける。疎な
行列、つまり要素のほとんどがゼロの行列なら、ラップトップ上でさえnが10億に達することもある。
しかし、これらの数を超える本当に巨大な問題では、近似的またはヒューリスティックな手法が必要になることが多い。
行列が大きくなり疎でなくなるほど、問題は扱いにくくなり、より巧妙なトリックを使わなければならない。行列が非常に
大きくて完全な対角化が選択肢にないとしよう。さらに、問題について十分な知識があり、
目標状態の全体的な構造についてある程度の推測ができ、初期の推測に似た状態を
探索してコストやエネルギーをさらに下げられるか確かめたいとする。これが変分アプローチであり、
古典コンピュータで完全な対角化が選択肢にない場合に使われる手法の一つだ。これは次のように機能する。
まず、変化させるパラメータthetaを持つ推測状態を作る。
この初期推測はランダムにすることもできるが、それは望ましくない。手元の問題についての知識を活用して
できる限り推測を調整したい。
第二に、その状態にあるシステムの演算子の期待値を計算する。
第三に、変分パラメータを変化させて繰り返す。
第四に、変分部分空間における可能な状態の景観について蓄積した情報を使って、より良い
推測を重ね、目標状態に近づく。
変分原理により、変分状態が目標基底状態より低い固有値をもたらすことはないことが保証されている。
だから期待値が低いほど、基底状態の近似が良いということだ。このアプローチにおける各ステップの
難しさについて話そう。
パラメータの設定や更新は計算上は簡単だ。難しいのは、物理的に意味のある
初期パラメータを選ぶことにある。以前の反復から蓄積した情報を使って基底状態に近づくような
パラメータの更新は非自明だ。しかし、これを
かなり効率的に行う古典的な最適化アルゴリズムが存在する。この古典的な最適化が高コストなのは、多くの
反復を必要とする場合があるからだ。最悪の場合、反復回数はnに対して指数的にスケールする。
計算上最も高コストな単一ステップは、ほぼ確実に、ある状態を使った行列の期待値の計算だ。
n×n行列がn要素のベクトルに作用しなければならず、これは最悪の場合n二乗の
乗算演算に対応する。これをパラメータの各反復で行う必要がある。非常に
大きな行列では、計算コストが高くなる。では、この計算の一部を
量子コンピュータに任せることを想像してほしい。この期待値を計算する代わりに、変分ansatzを使って量子コンピュータ上で
状態s(θ)を準備してから測定を行うことで推定する。
少し詳しく見てみよう。Hは一般的に測定が簡単ではない。例えば、多くの
非可換なPauli X、Y、Z演算子で構成されている場合がある。
しかしHは項H_αの線形結合として書ける。各項はそれぞれ簡単に測定できる。例えば、
Pauli演算子や、ビット単位で可換なPauli演算子のグループなどだ。
状態SにおけるHの期待値は、構成要素であるH_αの期待値の加重和だ。
この式は任意の状態sで成り立つが、具体的には変分状態s(θ)で使う。
各項h_αはm回測定でき、測定サンプルs_（jは1からmまで）が得られ、
期待値と標準偏差が返される。これらの項を合計し、
誤差を和を通じて伝播させることができる。
これは大規模な乗算もn二乗でスケールするような処理も必要としない。代わりに、
量子コンピュータ上での複数の測定が必要だ。それほど多くの測定が不要なら、このアプローチは
効率的になり得る。それがVQEの量子部分だ。しかし、これが効率的でない理由についても話そう。一つの理由は、
非常に高精度な計算において推定値の統計的不確かさを減らすために
多くの測定が必要になることだ。もう一つの理由は、行列全体を表すのに必要なPauli文字列の数だ。Pauli行列と
単位行列は特定の次元の全ての演算子の空間を張るので、
関心のある行列をPauli演算子の加重和として書けることが保証されている。ここでC_αは
数値係数で、H_αはシステムを記述する全てのqubitに作用するPauli演算子の文字列だ。
H_αはこのような形をしていて、右からn番目のPauli演算子がn番目のqubitに作用する。だから
一連のPauli演算子を測定することで演算子を測定できる。しかし、全てのPauli演算子を
同時に測定することはできない。単位行列を除くPauli演算子は、同じqubitに
関連付けられている場合、互いに可換でない。例えば、I Z、IIZ、ZZを
同時に測定できる。これは第三のqubitについてIとZを同時に測定でき、
第一のqubitについてIとXを同時に知ることができるからだ。しかし、
ZZZとZXを同時に測定することはできない。ZとXは可換でなく、
どちらも0番目のqubitに作用するからだ。
だから行列Hを異なるqubitに作用するPauliの和に分解する。
その和の一部の要素は一度に全て測定できる。これを可換なPauliのグループと呼ぶ。
非可換な項がいくつあるかに応じて、多くのグループが必要になる場合がある。可換な
Pauliのグループ数をNgcpと呼ぼう。
Ngcpが小さければ、うまく機能する可能性がある。
hが数百万のグループを持つなら、有用ではないだろう。状態で使ったパラメータthetaのセットに対する
期待値またはコスト関数を記録し、時間とともにパラメータを更新する。推定した
期待値またはコスト関数の値を使って、ansatzでサンプリングされた状態の部分空間における
コスト関数の勾配を近似できる。
勾配ベースと勾配フリーの両方の古典的なoptimizerが存在する。どちらも複数の局所最小値や、
バレンプラトーと呼ばれる勾配がほぼゼロのパラメータ空間の広い領域といった訓練可能性の問題に悩まされる。
ではVQEは最も難しい問題を全て解決するだろうか？いや、そうではない。しかし、全ての計算で優れていることは最初から目的ではなかった。
計算コストを決める要因が変わった。何を交換したか見てみよう。行列の次元だけに複雑さが依存するプロセスから、
必要な精度と行列を構成する非可換なPauli演算子の数に依存するものへと移行した。
最後の部分は古典計算には類似物がない。
これらの新しい依存関係に基づいて、疎な行列や非可換なPauli文字列が少ない行列では、
このプロセスが有用になる場合がある。これは相互作用するスピン系の場合に当てはまる。例えば、密な行列では
有用性が低い可能性がある。化学系では、数百、数千、さらには
数百万のPauli文字列を含むHamiltonianを持つことが多いと分かっている。この項の数を減らす興味深い研究がなされているが、
化学系はこのコースで扱う他のアルゴリズムの方が適している場合がある。
VQEを効果的に使うには、目標状態の属性を理解し、物理的に意味のある良い
初期状態と、変分パラメータが比較的少ない良いansatzを選べる必要がある。これは
かなり難しい場合がある。VQEは、最新の手法を追加せずとも、古典コンピュータと量子コンピュータの強みを組み合わせられることを示している。
VQEは古典コンピュータにとって扱いにくい問題を解くのに役立つわけではないが、
アルゴリズム開発において引き続き役割を果たしている。そしてVQEは、古典コンピュータから量子コンピュータへのステップの移行が
全ての目的において優れているわけでも劣っているわけでもないことを教えてくれる。むしろ、
アルゴリズムの効率を決める要因が変わるのだ。これは量子古典
ハイブリッド計算における重要な一般的教訓だ。